ja
bewusst demaskieren glaube ich wünsche
einen schönen vormittag hier beim
pressegespräch mit verteidigungsminister
in klaudia tanner und dem gesundheits
stadtrat peter hacker und darf die
verteidigungsministerin ersuchen zu
beginnen start-vertrag militärkommandant
vertreter der berufs heute ist aber dass
amerika bundes sehr geehrte damen und
herren schutz und hilfe wir sind wieder
da das österreichische bundesheer führt
wieder regie bei dem flächendeckenden
tests in wien die sehr erfolgreiche
zusammenarbeit
herr stadtrat der stadt wien und des
bundesheeres bei den testungen wird
fortgesetzt und es ist mir auch ein
persönliches bedürfnis danke zu sagen
danke für die bei der stadt wien bei den
sanitäterinnen und sanitäter in der
rettungsorganisationen und auch der
berufsfeuerwehr wien und insbesondere
auch bei dir herr militärkommandant in
einem miteinander ermöglichen wir in
einem sehr großen ausmaß gratis
testungen für die wienerinnen und wiener
und an dieser stelle hier auch nochmal
der aufruf unter appell an alle gehen
sie testen es sind wenige minuten
zeitaufwand und wir können so weitere
infektionsketten aufbrechen
bei diesen leistungen von acht bis zum
jänner in wien werden wir 1200
soldatinnen und soldaten aber auch
zivilbedienstete meines ressorts zum
einsatz erbringen die 43 test linien in
der messe wien werden dieses mal von der
dritten jägerbrigade mit 500 männern und
frauen betrieben die 30 test linien in
der max halle federführend durch die
garde und ich darf an dieser stelle
mitteilen ob es dass ich mich ganz
besonders stolz macht und freut dass die
24 test linien hier in
stadthalle federführend durch 250
milizsoldaten betrieben werden
sehr geehrte damen und herren im kampf
gegen das virus stehen uns im
wesentlichen zwei waffen zur verfügung
das eine ist das testen und das andere
ist die impfung der größte erfolgsfaktor
ist aber ohne zweifel dass die menschen
dass die bevölkerung mit macht diese
partizipation der bevölkerung denn je
mehr menschen regelmäßig testen gehen je
mehr menschen sich auch impfen lassen
desto schneller ist diese krise vorbei
ich darf mich bedanken nicht auf danke
sagen den soldatinnen und soldaten und
zivilbediensteten meines ressorts
ihr einsatz für unsere sicherheit der
ist unglaublicher ist unglaublich
wertvoll und österreich sieht wieder
einmal ohne unser her geht es nicht ein
ganz großes dankeschön abschließend noch
einmal an die stadt wien amtlicher
stadtrat an die berufsrettung an den
samariterbund für dieses miteinander im
kampf gegen die krise herzlichen dank
bitte herr stadtrat sagt damen und
herren sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin möchte mit den bank
wirklich anschließend in die andere
richtung
es ist nicht selbstverständlich was wir
hier organisieren schon im dezember
gelernt haben zu organisieren es ist
nicht selbstverständlich dass in so
einem großartigen kooperations klima
stattfindet und daran bist auch du
beteiligt im positiven sinne dank dafür
dass das so unproblematisch funktioniert
die vorbereitung die vorbereitung
machten jener staaten zukommen aber dass
solche aktion gelingt nur wenn über die
feiertage und zwar die wichtigsten
feiertage im jahr die in unserer
gesellschaft besondere bedeutung haben
wenn über diese feiertage an diesen
feiertagen alle zusammen unglaubliche
vorbereitungsarbeiten leistet und daher
kann man es gar nicht hoch genug
schätzen was es bedeutet ein management
zustande zu bringen
das am 8 jänner
eine delegation aktion möglich ist daher
wirklich herzlichen dank an die
kolleginnen und kollegen beim
österreichischen bundesheer die über die
feiertage gearbeitet haben
genauso wie der einsatzstab der stadt
die über die feiertage unabhängig von
den feiertagen die unglaubliche
vorbereitungs leistung zusammengebracht
haben
an die damen und herren bei der arbeit
das samaritern weil er wieder
berufsfeuerwehr auch bei der it
abteilung die abteilung hat mir gestern
mitgeteilt sie sind ganz stolz dass sie
fertig sind
aber ich meine es war feiertag und die
haben einfach unabhängig davon dass
feiertag war haben die diese
höchstleistung von prag sämtliche tische
ein drei hallen thema kreative sie
perfekt zu verbinden was so wichtige
grundvoraussetzung ist dass überhaupt
ein derartiger logistische leistung auf
den boden bringen können
wir sind sehr zuversichtlich dass die
abwicklung wieder so reibungslos
funktioniert wie im dezember
und es sind vorbereitet auf bis zu einer
million test wenn es notwendig sein
sollte 900 18.000 genau ist die derzeit
ausgelegte des kapazität werden wir
machen blick anmeldungen in der höhe von
41.000 mensch aber ich bin ganz
zuversichtlich und biete auch sie alle
dafür werbung zu machen dass wenn wir
das jetzt bekannt gegeben dass jetzt
beginnt das zu achten
bis 17 die drei hallen wieder geöffnet
sind dass die zahl der anmeldungen sehr
sprunghaft nach oben geht
wir haben im augenblick in wien eine
andere situation in der entwicklung der
epidemie sind in anderen bundesländern
da kann man lange darüber diskutieren
welche gründe es hat aber ein grund ist
ganz sicherlich mit einer großen
hartnäckigkeit machen wir seit vielen
monaten werbung dafür dass die menschen
rechtzeitig testen gehen und zwar auch
zu dem zeitpunkt wo sie keine symptome
verspüren einfacher sicherheitsgründen
aus emotionalen gründen weil sie aber
bis dezember schon darüber gesprochen
und wenn es nur das seele gut tut hat
seinen sinn
aber es tut eben nicht nur sehr gut
sondern über alle wochen
jeden tag menschen gefunden die keine
symptome gehabt haben und trotzdem
positiv gewesen sind und konnten dadurch
verhindern dass die optimierenden
größere ausbreitung hat als das in
vielen anderen ländern dieses dieser als
dieses europa genau genommen der fall
ist und daher auch hier jetzt mal ab
edel meine bitte zum zusammenhalt dass
wir diese testmöglichkeit noch wirklich
nutzen viele menschen haben die
feiertage zu hause verbracht im kleinen
familienkreis manche waren auch wenn
familienangehörigen die nicht in wien zu
hause sind und für alle diese menschen
gilt sehr herzlich die einladung sich
sicherheitshalber testen zu lassen
dieses angebot zu nutzen
die organisation ist großartig wir sind
uns ganz sicher dass du so perfekt
funktioniert wie sie funktioniert hat im
dezember aus den fehlern dass er zweimal
haben wir auch gelernt dass in einigen
punkten noch effizienter geworden
wir können der ein bisschen und weniger
personal einsetzen wissen dass wir dafür
die flaschenhälse in den abläufen
prozessen definieren konnten
herausfinden konnten und möglicherweise
sogar noch schneller sind für den
einzelnen was bedeutet die wartezeiten
für den einzelnen sind wahrscheinlich
noch viel kürzer als das im dezember der
fall auch dass das ergebnis einer
exzellenten zusammenarbeit zwischen
allen beteiligten organisationen die
ganz ohne emotionen ganz genau
analysiert haben wo können wir noch
besser werden und daher noch einmal zum
abschluss mein dank an alle beteiligten
nach der dichte nebel bundesministerin
das gar nicht selbstverständlich wie
organisationen die unterschiedlichen
gebietskörperschaften zugeordnet werden
die unterschiedliche kulturen haben die
unterschiedliche traditionen haben wie
großartig da die zusammenarbeit ist so
stellen wir uns das vor
und dafür stehen wir auch beide
gemeinsam und ich danke vielmals dafür
dass sie die bevölkerung darüber
informieren
es ist schon möglich sich anzumelden wie
gesagt wir haben kein und 40.000
anmeldungen bitte viel werbung dafür zu
machen wieder regelmäßig zum testen zu
gehen wenn jemand zweimal geben will
schadet es auch nicht
man kann am achten gehen man kann dann
am 17 noch einmal gehen schaden
überhaupt nicht wenn man zwei mal testen
ist und dann einen einwöchigen abstand
zu schlimmer gewesen hat danke vielmals
vielen dank ich darf nun um ihre fragen
bieten und dass sie suchen zu warten bis
das mikrofon bei ihnen ist der stadtrat
hacker ich hab' ich habe eine frage zur
impfung und zwar wäre es für sie denkbar
dass man diese infrastruktur die man
hier für die massentests geschaffen hat
auch für die impfung für impfstraßen
nutzen könnte in zukunft und eine zweite
frage noch der bedarf in den
pflegeheimen soll ungefähr also nur die
hälfte sollen bedarf angemeldet haben
wie schaut denn da in wien aus wie will
man da den bedarf noch ankurbeln wie
will man eine pflegeheime herangehen ja
wir lernen natürlich mit solchen
organisationen die ja gerne
selbstverständlich sind lernen wir auch
schon für das was passieren wird meiner
einschätzung nach eher aus dem zweiten
quartal des heurigen jahres nämlich die
große die große flächenmäßige impfung
dafür lernen wir
damit haben wir begonnen zu lernen wie
wir die im straßen aufgebaut haben für
die grippeimpfung wir haben gelernt im
dezember und wir lernen jetzt wieder wie
können wir das organisieren eine extrem
große anzahl von menschen sehr rasch mit
einer hohen qualität auch in der
administration gut so zu servicieren mit
gesundheitsdienstleistungen
unterschiedlicher art die
gesundheitsdienstleistungen testen auf
der einen seite die
gesundheitsdienstleistern impfen auf der
anderen seite jahre lernen dazu und es
ist sehr denkbar dass wir so ähnliche in
positur aufbauen
wir werden aber erst im zweiten quartal
in der situation sein dass auch wirklich
zu benötigen
im augenblick sind wir bei den
spezifischen zielgruppen im augenblick
alten und pflegeheime die mitarbeiter
genauso wie der bewohner und auf der
zweiten seite die mitarbeiterinnen
später abteilungen den besonders
kritischen bereiche spitals tätig sind
das in unseren abteilungen
die notfallaufnahme abteilungen und
ähnliches das ist im augenblick die top
priorität und da geht es in der
skalierung die sie ohne die scanner
weiter und wie gesagt ich schätze im
zweiten quartal wird so weit sein dass
er dann auch wirklich in solche großen
strukturen hinein gehen werde nur dann
massenhaft impfen können die die
beteiligungs- rate in den pflegeheimen
ist soweit großen befriedigung
überraschend hoch wir haben in den
pflegeheimen zwar bisserl
unterschiedliche situation man kann
jetzt sagen es ist in allen gleich da
wir haben einrichtung mit bis zu 80
prozent in bereitschaft und bzw
teilweise schon nach durchgeimpft von
bewohnerinnen und bewohnern bei
mitarbeitern ist ein bisschen niedriger
liegt ungefähr bei 70 prozent
also ich habe da kann man sehr zufrieden
sein ich habe von anfang an gesagt ich
hab es wichtig sein die richtigen
vorbilder zu haben und habe deswegen
auch meinen experten geist
vorgeschlagene übergehen und mit dem
professor wenig um ein klares zeichen zu
setzen ein klares symbol zu setzen dass
jemand der so eine expertise hat wie er
die unschlagbar ist der auch bekannt ist
für seine expertise sich als erstes
impfen lassen das hat glaube ich ganz
viel ausgelöst und war glaube ich ein
sehr wichtiges symbol handlung auch und
wer kann besser auskunft geben was da
für so wenig über die richtigkeit und
notwendigkeit einer solchen impfung und
ich habe es hat viel dazu beigetragen
das kriege ich auch das feedback von
vielen menschen das ist ein gut wenn
sich der professor
ich verlasse das erst dann los ich
glaube das ist wichtig ist und daher war
ich immer sehr zuversichtlich dass es
gelingt die bereitschaft sehr sehr rasch
nach oben zu bringen
und je mehr erfahren wir als
gesellschaft haben mit diesen impfungen
desto geringer wird diese bedeutung
seien von dieser kleinen mini gruppe
glaubt dass das immer besser wissen und
alles was mit ihm von gesunder zu tun
ist irgendwo in der karen ein kapitel in
der nostradamus büchern wiederzufinden
ist die wird belanglos sein diese
widerstandsgruppe ehrlich gesagt wie
ganz überzeugt davon ein sehr sehr
großer teil der bevölkerung wird sich in
den nächsten wochen und monaten nach auf
unserer form erklärt von an
nächste frage bitte statt der zuerst
eine technische frage hier kann man
jetzt hier bei den ganzen impfstraßen
bei den stationen nur mit anmeldung
kommen oder wird es auch so sein wie sie
im dezember dann zum schluss war dass
man ohne anmeldung auch kommen konnte
also das hat sich technische frage dann
auch vielleicht zum thema impfstoff
bitte
es gab ein bisschen diskussionen darüber
über die verteilung der impfdosen in den
bundesländern warum hat kärnten mehr
dosen bekommen wie wien ist es jetzt für
die zukunft für die nächsten
auslieferungen aus ihrer sicht klar
welches bundesland wie viele dosen
bekommt und bekommt winter auch genug
ist dieser schlüssel logisch und
stringent aus ihrer sicht als ich
verstehe die aufregung in exakt in den
letzten zwei tagen zur endeavour nicht
ganz kann das nicht ganz nachvollziehen
wir haben im dezember über das thema
schon diskutiert werden dezember der
ersten planwerte bekommen kann erinnern
was sie zum kurz vor weihnachten wo wir
die sehr konkrete liefermengen genannt
bekommen haben für die ersten wochen für
die ersten kalenderwoche sagen jahres es
ist völlig logisch und nachvollziehbar
dass angesichts der frage im dezember
nach welche impfstoffe werden überhaupt
zugelassen keine supertolle planungs
werte am tisch liegen können dass ich da
gar nicht möglich gewesen
man hat gehofft dass drei impfstoffe
zugelassen werden wir alle wissen hat es
nur einer geschafft im dezember die
liefermengen waren daher bescheiden aber
ende dezember haben wir schon gewusst
welche liefermengen bekommen wir von dem
impfstoff vom kaiser für die ersten
kalenderwoche und darauf aufbauend haben
wir unsere impfstrategie aufgebaut und
sie erinnern sich da ist dann aufgrund
eines wunsches der europäischen
kommission vorverlegt worden da im staat
auf den 27 um europaweit eine symbolik
zu setzen es war immer klar kommuniziert
das ist ein symbol akt ist am 27
wir haben damals schon gesagt dass wir
in wien nicht warten werden bis auf den
12 ich habe damals schon gesagt wir
werden in wien sicher schon in der
ersten kalenderwoche das sagen jahres
impfen nämlich dass für impfen was uns
an impfstoff erstens zur verfügung steht
und zweitens natürlich auch der
medizinischen logik folgt wir wissen
dass wir zwei impfungen brauchen pro
person mit einem mehrwöchigen abstand
aber ich will natürlich völlig idiotisch
die menschen zu impfen mit allem was
verfügbar ist und dann drei wochen
später keinen impfstoff zu haben weil
die liefermengen zu geringsten der
führen daher braucht seine präzise
planung gemacht in wien ein einsatzstab
das ist durchgeplant schon seit dezember
also ich verstehe die diskussion jetzt
nicht ganz offen ehrlich gesagt
jedenfalls erwin war immer klar die
machen keine pause sondern gehen sofort
in die spitals einrichtungen hinein
sofort in die pflegeeinrichtungen hinein
und diesen plan setzen wir jetzt auch
genauso wie ende dezember festgelegt
wurde vom einsatz stand herr stadtrat im
dezember bei dem massentest sondern auch
ein gefälle erkennbar zwischen defiziten
dies weiter zu den teststationen haben
und dies näher zu den sechs stationen
haben wieso gibt bei den jetzigen
massentest nicht auf da im 21 122 bezirk
teststationen für die massentest oder
generell mehr
erst einmal ist eine frage der logistik
zweiten mal im 22 bezirk haben wir die
größte des stationen das überhaupt gibt
für den routinebetrieb mann aus der
center vienna und haben auch dort
gesehen dass es keine bezirks bezirke
gibt aber auch für die bevölkerung im
süden und dem westen wiens gilt dass der
öffentliche verkehr zur verfügung steht
viele menschen kommen auch mit dem auto
und ich kann jetzt nicht erkennen dass
da jemand großartig benachteiligt ist
und dass alle distanz frage ist es ist
auch vom süden wien eine eine fahrzeit
von ge schätzung über sieben minuten bis
zur werkshalle und ungefähr neun minuten
bis zur messe also exakt kann das nicht
ganz nachvollziehen warum das nicht
erreichbar sein sollte warum tun wir so
kann ich ihnen schon beantworten wir
haben uns mit der frage der logistik
natürlich beschäftigt
wie können wir so effizient wie möglich
organisieren und gleichzeitig technisch
auf bestmöglichem stand sein das geht
darum dass wir hier erinnern die
administration machen wollen wir wollen
dass die menschen das gesamte prozedere
inklusive pcr test um erledigt haben
wenn sie aus der halle wieder rausgehen
und das in der schnellstmöglichen zeit
und dazu braucht es eine mindestfläche
und wir sind hier der stadtteile wenn
man reingehen immer alle beeindruckt wie
groß das ist aber es ist die kleinste
alle verneigen und viel kleiner darf
eine halle nicht sein und so viele große
hallen haben heute in wien apa red
es gab noch eine haarlem 22 bezirk
bekannterweise ist eine eislaufhalle in
der eislaufhalle gibt es eine kleine
eisfläche die nicht benutzt wird wir
haben uns das angeschaut die stäbe waren
dort vor ort und haben dann abgeraten
weil wir dort einfach viel zu wenig des
kapazität zustande bringen für das was
unser vorhaben hier ist und daher muss
man einfach akzeptieren wir haben
einfach die hallen nicht die flächen
nicht wenn sie eine anschauen da zahlen
wir haben jetzt aufgebaut
insgesamt 117 test linien 117 test
linien in den 3
alleine hier in der stadthalle haben wir
24 test linien plus 5
also 29 gestrigen aufgebaut 24 anti
gehen und fünf dann für die nachfolge
der pca desto in unserer größten test
straße außerhalb des acv im prater
stadion haben wir sechs test linien
stellen sie dann mal vor wie groß der
barcodes sein muss um diese zahl von
test drinnen die wir hier in der halle
haben auf der straße zustande zu bringen
die fläche gibt es einfach nicht in wien
bekennt eventuell die westeinfahrt
sperren bekennten die südautobahn
sperren und dann kenntnis eventuell
hinkriegen natürlich vollkommen absurd
wäre aber es gibt die flächen aber nicht
wir müssen zur kenntnis nehmen dass in
einer stadt mit begrenzten flächen
ressourcen und daher ist die
entscheidung richtig getroffen worden
von den krisenstäben vollen am ende des
tages von uns beiden entschieden dass
wir dabei bleiben in diesen drei hallen
wo wir schon bewährte aufbau logik haben
zu bleiben und diese tests durchzuführen
weitere fragen bietet reiche
anschließend die drei permanenten
kreisstraßen bleiben die in dieser
version wie es jetzt ist oder wird da
vielleicht weniger geben oder wird man
eine zusätzliche machen
ich hab so weit verstanden die
permanenten test straßen ja hier jetzt
der schon erwähnt wurden ja werden die
bis auf weiteres in betrieb bleiben oder
wird sie auch änderungen geben die
schließungen oder zusätzliche stationen
zu männern während der massentest und
mainz ist auf längerfristige während der
massentest sondern werden sie bestehen
bleiben aber mit reduzierter kapazität
logischerweise machte keinen sinn und
wir wären jetzt einmal schauen wie die
nächsten tage passieren wie weit wird
die kapazität dort reduzieren aber
jedenfalls die beiden 341 praterstadion
fletcher verbleiben vor inhaltlich
bestehen jedenfalls der drive-in im
austria center wie weit wir dann beim
wort ihn im autocenter bleiben das wird
man skalieren je nach bedarf macht
keinen sinn oder ressourcen vorzuhalten
wenn auf der anderen seite in drei
jahren eine derartige aktion stattfindet
langfristig bleiben alle diese des
kapazitäten bestehend alle verträge sind
langfristiger abgeschlossen und ich bin
überzeugt davon wir werden noch viele
monate
eine hohe kapazität kapazität brauchen
und wie eingangs schon gesagt habe ich
bin auch sehr stolz dass es glaube ich
in wien gut gelungen ist das testen zu
erleben nicht spektakulären vorgang zu
machen im bewusstsein der wiener
bevölkerung glaube das ist einer der
ganz wichtigen elemente das ist nichts
spektakuläres sie sich testen gehen zu
lassen sondern sehr einfacher war dieser
doris auch einfacher und dieser vorgang
wird
danke weitere fragen anschließen der
kollegen gefragt die anmeldung für die
massen es ist nötig oder hat man
vielleicht wieder umsteigen auf login
ohne anmeldung im augenblick ist die
anmeldung notwendig aber sie kennen
unsere flexibilität schon vom dezember
wir werden das auch diesmal so handhaben
jetzt in den ersten tagen bitte ich um
verständnis wollen wir bei der anmeldung
bleiben
je nachdem wie dann der zulauf ist
werden wir sicher sehr rasch dann
umschalten dass wir wieder ohne
anmeldung in die messehalle gehen kann
nach hinten nur noch eine frage bei der
ersten runde der stadtrat war die
beteiligung in wien bei 14 prozent also
schlusslicht im österreich-vergleich wie
hoch wollen sie die quote jetzt heben
haben sie da ein konkretes ziel
ja ich habe da schon dezember gesagt
hast wenn du in einer stadt wie wir es
im dezember schon hatten im november
200.000 tests gemacht hast
da darf so eine revanche sein dass
massen testen diese aktion der
bundesregierung dann einen besonders
hohen zulauf hat also es immer eine
frage wie ist die test kultur und die
traditionen in einer stadt oder einer
gemeinde oder dem bundesland und daher
war es schon im dezember nicht
überraschend aber trotzdem sind wir das
bundesland das jesus haben dann
vierthaler teils dieser republik bis
jetzt gemacht hat um 1,5 millionen tests
gemacht in wien in den vergangenen jahr
und daher hat das in wien eine andere
routine
ich glaube dass der zulauf wird ein
bisschen höher sein wird als wie in dem
routine geschäft der letzten wochen
außerhalb des massentests aber ich bin
doch ich werde nicht überrascht sein
wenn wir nicht eine million tests haben
wir
wir werden wohl weniger haben aber wir
sind darauf vorbereitet und das ist
notwendig klare klare ansage von uns wir
sind vorbereitet auf über 900.000 tests
in diesen in diesen in diesem zeitraum
von 8 bis zu 17
ich glaube dass keine 900.000 test
stattfinden werden aber es geht an einer
wahren wettbewerb und es geht ein
ranking oder ähnliches oder es geht nach
wie vor hinter die kentix wunder dass
politische maßnahmen und da gibt es kein
wettbewerb sondern geht es darum den
menschen zu motivieren diese
gelegenheiten zu nutzen und auch in
anspruch zu nehmen
keine frage zuletzt war ja auch dieser
sogenannte eingangstest in diskussionen
da gibt es verschiedene vorschläge und
ideen wie sehr ihre position dass ein
solcher test und möglicherweise sinnvoll
sein könnte so es ist immer
wir haben eine komische kultur
entwickelt in unserem land das ist schon
vor sträflich ist öffentlich zu äußern
ich finde die idee nachvollziehbar und
ich halte es für wert zu prüfen ob sie
auch umsetzen können so war das auch bei
der beiden letzten manöver dass es gibt
auf der politischen ebene diskussion die
ist vorgeschlagen worden
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere von
bundeskanzler dass er gesagt vielleicht
sollten auch was probieren in diese
richtung und jetzt geht es darum dass
das ministerium dazu ein gesetzestext
vorliegt und der ist doch entweder
umsetzbar oder nicht umsetzbar
was halte ich von der idee grundsätzlich
grundsätzlich braucht mich niemand
überzeugen von der intelligenz das
getestet wird
und der ist es durchaus nachvollziehbar
zu versuchen es auf rechtlich saubere
beine zu stellen
ob das gelingt kann er beurteilen das
wird man sehen und wenn es nicht gelingt
weil es einen grenzen eines
demokratischen freien landes rütteln
dann werden wir es nicht umsetzen können
dann muss man andere wege finden aber
das ist auch zu unterscheiden
das eine ist was kann der staat für
gesetzliche zwangsmaßnahmen verordnen
das zweite ist was ist
gesundheitspolitisch scheiter idee es
ist zweifelsohne geschadet dass die
menschen sehr oft sehr viel leisten
es ist gescheiter idee in einem freien
land die menschen zu dick und zu zwingen
die verfassung die menschen beschützt
und darum geht es jetzt immer haben wir
jetzt geht es einmal darum zu schauen
gibt es anscheinend gesetzesvorschlag
wie wir das umsetzen kann dann kann man
das politisch diskutieren kann was
politisch bewerten und dann kann man
sagen setzt bloß rum oder nicht gut
herzlichen dank inzwischen sind die
milizsoldaten die jetzt morgen hier die
tests machen draußen eingetroffen
und es gibt es die möglichkeit eines
fototermins mit der frau
bundesministerin der hand
gesundheitsstadtrat und den
milizsoldaten die dann auf morgen die
tests machen werden das ist draußen